[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brandon huffman
he is the 24 7 sports national
recruiting editor here to talk about
just how good this alabama recruiting
class was
and is it truly generational and uh
brandon joins us now brandon thanks for
joining us
uh where does this alabama recruiting
class rank
well it just clinched the top overall
spot in the history of 24 7 sports
recruiting rankings
and they still may not be done they're
still in contention for the number one
player in the country
but as of this morning they have already
inked with
the pen putting paper the number one
class in the history of recruiting
with some of the most elite talent that
you've seen it's on par with their 2017
class that they signed
with devonta smith and naji harris but
this class
might be nick saban's best class that
he's ever signed which is saying
something considering the success he's
had
in tuscaloosa the best recruiting class
prior to alabama this year was turned in
by
florida yeah for it in 2010 and
you'd say that might have been the class
that broke urban meyer at florida and
caused him to eventually walk away from
that job this class looks a little bit
less risky than that florida 2010 class
did
and a lot of guys that i expect to play
right away but it wasn't just
guys on the offensive line defensive
line as nick saban always does
he gets players at every key position
and that's why this class ranks so high
where did you guys have patrick mahomes
when he was coming out of high school
so he was ranked as a high three star
coming out in that 2014 class behind
guys like kyle allen
keller chris at the time was committed
to stanford was being taught as the next
andrew luck
mahomes was kind of forgotten a little
bit uh part of that reason was there was
still a thinking that he might go the
baseball route there wasn't even
certainty
he was going to be a football player
baseball was still looming there as a
potential threat for him but
he was a high three star and ultimately
made a lot of people look really foolish
with that decision
and trevor lawrence was number one and
here he is going to go number one in the
draft
uh justin fields was two in that
recruiting class
and he'll be a first-round draft pick so
you know
we hit and miss at that position but
you're no different than the general
managers in the
nfl sure and i think when you look at
that lawrence fields class i mean there
was debate for
part of that year who was better trevor
lawrence started out as the number one
player justin fields moved ahead
ultimately with trevor lawrence it looks
like he's going to be the number one
pick
in the 2021 draft but those two were as
good of a one-two punch as you've ever
seen
and now three years later we look good
on that but there have been plenty of
classes where you had guys
the 2013 class of max brown and
christian hackenberg
those look like the safest one to punch
max brown never really got it going at
usc
or at pit christian hackenberg had an up
and down career so
you have your misses you want to follow
those misses up with hits rather than go
the other direction
give me the couple of names at that
position that we'll be talking about in
in two years well the two top
quarterbacks in the country
are caleb williams who's the number one
dual threat quarterback out of the
uh washington dc he's already at
oklahoma
going in with the understanding that
spencer allen is going to be the starter
at least in 2021
and then williams will have a chance to
compete for that job and then the number
one pro style quarterback is a familiar
name to
fans out west in the name of sam hewitt
quarterback got a kennedy catholic high
school
in durian washington his father gaiman
former nfl quarterback his uncle brock
former nfl quarterback both of his dad
and his uncle
played quarterback at the university of
washington he actually committed to the
huskies two years ago
when chris peterson was still the head
coach stayed with that commitment to
washington despite some late overtures
from usc and some other schools so he's
the guy that even with dylan morris
starting this year as a freshman
i wouldn't be surprised if he competes
for the starting job whereas caleb
williams like a couple of the oklahoma
quarterbacks before him
probably has to wait at least a year
before we start to become with the next
link in riley's sensation
where is the number one recruit on 24 7
going
well that's a very good question we're
still trying to figure that out and it's
probably going to be two months
that player is jt tui molo out of
eastside catholic and samantha
washington
he on the early signing period named his
final five of alabama ohio state
washington oregon and usc so you have
three pac-12 schools relatively close to
home
one being the hometown huskies another
being oregon which is just down the road
usc where his family is largely from
southern california
then you have the two teams playing for
the national championship and it's
really been
those two teams out in front for him
alabama and ohio state
part of the reason he's waiting is with
the ncaa dead period he has never had a
chance to visit columbus he still has
not been out to ohio state
he did camp at alabama when he was a
sophomore so he wants to get back down
to tuscaloosa and get out to columbus
with his family
to see both those schools he's more
familiar with the pac-12 schools but
we're at least two months away from him
making a decision ohio state alabama
played for the national championship
now they're playing to see who gets the
number one overall player but those
three pac-12
was trying to get relevance back into
the conference are hoping he decides to
stay closer to home
brandon we talk about this on the show
occasionally ole miss
tennessee where sometimes you don't
expect a school to have a
really really good recruiting class and
when you do that
all of a sudden that's when people start
to notice
did anybody have an out of the ordinary
recruiting class this year you know
tennessee had it last spring they paid
the price
this year anybody that you look at and
you go wow
i didn't expect them to be up in the top
10 or top 15.
yeah i would say you know maryland is
just outside the top 15
considering the struggles they've had on
the field the last few years
it is kind of a surprise to see maryland
rank so high especially when
that state's been really bleeding the
top players in the state
maryland has become a frequent stop for
big ten schools for acc
schools for sec schools and they've had
a hard time keeping them
but mike blocksley ever since he was at
florida when he was at new mexico
alabama he's always been known as a
recruiter always been known as one of
the best recruiters in fact
he was one of the first coaches in all
of college football to start getting
bonuses based on where his recruiting
class ranked
which kind of dispelled the longtime
myth that coaches said rankings don't
matter when
there was 50 60 000 reasons for it to
matter
mike loxy's been able to overcome kind
of an up and down start to his career at
maryland as the head coach
by following up with a very good
recruiting effort in the last couple
years
culminating with the top 20 class so
when you see maryland in there and kind
of sandwich between
schools that you expect to be there it
is one of those schools that does
have you scratching your head a little
bit but if you look at locksley's
history as a recruiter
it's not as surprising as saves when
hugh freeze had ole miss in the top 10
or tennessee
with their struggles ended up with the
top 10 class how did sark do at texas
serge inherited the large number of
these guys had already signed with tom
herman
it was a top 20 class already when he
got there now
one of the big things for them is that
they've already gotten a commitment from
one of the top running backs in the
country
for next year he committed yesterday so
they were hoping to get lj johnson who
was the top
uncommitted back in the state of texas
it's looking like he's going to choose
texas a m
but stark really the big thing for him
was getting that top running back to
commit for 2022
and really what it's going to come down
to for stark is how does he do
with the efforts of queen euers who was
once committed to texas
decommitted committed ohio state he's
the number one player in the country for
2022.
can sark get texas back in it or it's
putting you or the lost
cause but i think considering the timing
of when sarp was hired
being in january he's walking into a
pretty well put together class
2022 is going to be that first class
we're really going to be able to judge
just how well a job sarkeesian's doing
as a recruiter at the university
of texas thank you brandon we had a lot
of fun looking at the website today
and uh we appreciate your time thank you
i appreciate it that's brandon huffman
national recruiting editor for
2 24 7.